we are just three days away from the
first junior edition of Dancing with the
Stars we're excited because it is that
good trust me it is that good and that
adorable I mean more than you can even
imagine right all right and we know
because we were first on the set my goal
for the competition
it's so exciting the top three do
hip-hop dance at all yeah - what - it's
a car TV
thank you let's do this so is cardi B
honey Boo Boo's ballroom secret weapon
let's go find out easy with exclusively
inside the soundstage as 12 little
Mirabal hopefuls rehearsed for Sunday's
big chimere's amongst the juniors cast
blackish star miles Brown Bristol
Palin's nine-year-old son Tripp and
13-year old man Lou Morris I'm a fashion
designer and also my dad a Stevie Wonder
mandalas mentor - time dancing champ and
pro Cheryl Burke I'm not you know really
a dancer
and from one camp to another spelling
bee whiz akaash pakodi I knew obviously
dancing is not my field excel in
non-academic feel it's like dance but
keep an eye on - ten year-old pint-sized
powerhouses Avengers infinity war star
Ariana green black and skateboarding
prodigy Skye Brown I wanted to show
girls I can do anything be brave and do
it cuz you love it I just love dancing
in general I can really show off my
personality and I get to show America
that moves
I did a tiny bit of dancing when I was
much younger Houston also I danced aloud
with my dad in the kitchen very cute
yeah this like the grownup version of
the show America won't get to vote on
the juniors the studio audience will be
combined with the judges to decide who
goes home can they all just call painful
is that gonna be what you said I was
gonna do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]